Sall Paolantonio is the author of a new
book called philly special and the
inside story of how the Eagles won their
first Superbowl championship now on sale
online wherever books are sold Sal pal
good to talk to you where are you this
morning I am sitting outside the Nova
count facility and the Philly furnace
knowing that South Philadelphia it's
it's gonna be pretty bad Thursday night
at the confluence of i-95 in the
Schuylkill Expressway in a concrete
jungle of South Philly that's gonna be
hot and humid gonna be rough night all
right as far as the team itself Doug
Peterson has already been a little testy
with the media over who's starting and
we can get to that but the overall
assessment of this team with a after the
Super Bowl hangover is how good are they
this year I think they're going to be
better on defense I don't think they're
going to be better on offense now they
were third in the league in points
allowed last year and third in the
league and points scored and I think
you'll see that sort of come together a
little bit so they're they're not going
to score 28.3 points per game their
leading rusher is in Detroit the leading
receiver from last year Alshon Jeffery
hasn't practice he's still recovering
from shoulder surgery they're going to
have to make do with a lot of tight end
double tight end sets a lot of formation
variation I'm giving you some matchup
jargon now I know it's a little early
for that kind of stuff I apologize but
uh they're gonna have to do a lot of
shifts and motions get creative I think
you'll see a little Chip Kelly light in
other words 2.1 seconds get the ball out
of your hands I think you'll see a lot
more RPO than you did last year I think
with that combination of creativity
they'll manufacture some points but
they're not that Dan they're not going
to bully anybody on the line of
scrimmage because they just don't have
that back and they're not going to be
pyrotechnic as they just don't have that
wide receiver Mike Wallace has really
shown very
very little in training camp and this
summer at all and he still can run a
nine route he can still occupy a safety
deep and that may help you control the
hashes with the rookie Dallas Goddard
and the Provo tight end Zach Ertz but
they're not going to light the
scoreboard up defensively their
secondary is going to be good dad it's
going to be really really good it so
it's always been a smart secondary with
Malcolm Jenkins and Ronnie McCloud and
now you got some young hungry corners
Ronald Darby's real hungry he's in a
contract year this kid I want a Maddox
they got out of pit can't play if he was
511 he'd be a first-round pick he's got
speed inside quickness he's talking hit
you in the mouth Sydney Jones is coming
back from that Achilles he can play
Rasul Douglas he's from East Orange New
Jersey he brings that attitude so they
got some corners from young corners
they're gonna play well in the secondary
they really are coach Peterson a little
testy with the reporter the other day
and this is how it sounded first of all
I appreciate y'all putting words in my
mouth this week and therefore I'm not
gonna discuss it put in your mouth you
saw the reports next question so sound
so why is coach so testy about this you
know I've covered duck since he was a
quarterback here under Donovan McNabb I
never thought I would say these words
Doug Peterson was channeling his inner
juice
well what we're not we're not at war
with Doug Peterson here it's a love
affair it's it's a marriage that
continues a honeymoon that continues to
go on and on and on and on and on so I
don't understand
and he's pushed all the right buttons
for the last two years he went rogue on
us on Sunday it was
it was it was honestly very out of
character I'm not mama gonna hammer him
over it and because you know he has been
very accessible and given us a lot of
you know good inside information about
the team and really opened up any person
like I said all the right buttons last
year so he gets a mulligan on that one
but you know it it was it wasn't pretty
he's got a press conference here coming
up in a couple of minutes in Nova care
so I'm anxious to see how he how he
handles today yeah why don't you just
bring it up on say it coach can you give
me a timeframe on Carson Wentz coming
back please actually why don't I just go
straight to a frozen house next question
next question the book is Philly special
of course that led to a touchdown for
Nick Foles why'd you pick that as your
title when'd you start thinking about
the book well the title was picked by
the publisher and I thought they did a
smart thing the book is really resonated
nationally because the team really
became America's team last year and for
a lot of different reasons I started
thinking about the book when they were
on the nine game win streak and then I
shelved it obviously when Carson Wentz
got hurt and I honestly you know when
you're underdogs the Falcons and the
Vikings and the Patriots you're not
thinking about writing a book about a
championship team and then it just
happened real quickly it's like
publisher sent the contract and I I went
on this labor of love and the books not
for me Dan I covered the team for a
quarter of a century 25 years when you
do something like that as you know you
miss a lot of Saturday night dinners you
miss a lot of Sunday's with your family
for 25 years so the books from my family
the guy who cuts my hair is an Eagles
fan the guy cuts my lawn my mailman is
an Eagles fan and for 25 years they've
asked me the same questions about the
team and I really wanted to write a book
that was the definitive inside a cow
the first Super Bowl championship and
and leave it as a legacy and and give it
to my family as a thank you and that I
think the book really resonates with
people because it was an underdog story
I'm not a national underdog story well
congrats on it and I wish you nothing
but success and I know you got to go is
the meeting starting in in a couple of
seconds here with coach Peterson okay
all right I mean I'm on with Dan Patrick
I don't want you to get in trouble
good idea yeah I don't want you to get
yelled at by anybody at the mothership
there so definitely not it's been a long
and beautiful writing the book I really
appreciate it thank you so Sal
Paolantonio ESPN NFL national
correspondent and author of Philly
special thanks good for him for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]